so
so
elizabeth queen of scots
slips from view
in this her northern kingdom
accompanied by her husband princess
royal along with
lieutenant colonel mike vernon the
comptroller of the lord chamberlain's
office
and the lord steward the elder dalhousie
making their way to the globemaster c17
which will shortly lift away from this
airport
and turn south
heading for london
and the next stage in this
noble farewell to elizabeth ii
the signs of the ramp being put into
place
sealing this precious cargo for the
journey
to england
the queen's generation who in their
salad days is
elizabeth ii often used to refer to it
remembered the signs of the lancaster
bombers the
spitfires and the hurricanes the raw the
throatiness of those aircraft that
fought
to defend the freedom
that the queen
largely had the privilege
of reigning over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
elizabeth queen of scots lifts into the
skies
and not long ago her son the new king
addressed the scottish parliament
and he said
if i might paraphrase
the words of the great robert burns
[Music]
my dear mother was
the friend of man
the friend of truth
the friend of age
and guide of youth
few hearts
like hers
with virtue warmed
few heads with knowledge
so informed